joining me now for reaction is historian
Victor Davis Hanson a senior fellow at
the Hoover Institution alright Vth
usually have you out in the morning and
radio but we have a onion night tonight
and you're even peppier at night I know
that for historian your reaction to the
angle and then we're gonna get into some
of these other topics well I think
you're right that it's inverse of what
the so-called deep state establishments
say they said the post-war was sober
judicious and stable and this guy came
in without prior political office or
military service and disrupted it but
what if it was the other way around it
was chaotic and it didn't make sense and
somebody without exposure to their
protocols had a set of skill set sort of
like John Wayne in the searchers or the
white Bill hold in the Wild Bunch and he
came in and said this is ridiculous and
that's what he's doing in all of these
instances that you pointed out whether
it was as crazy open border or was this
nut with missiles pointed out us here in
the West Coast or whether it was NATO
members not paying their contributions
and on and on in Syria to reply in
particular he's got a lot of dilemmas
though he didn't create this situation
Russia was brought in after 40 years by
Susan Rice and John Kerry and then they
assured us that there were no WMDs Susan
Rice said that in January of last year
so Trump comes in and there is WMD and
there we've lost all sense of deterrence
because of this lead behind recessions
and yet he doesn't want and can't get
involved in the way that we did in
Afghanistan and Iraq
so he's in between those two polls and
everybody who's suspicious of going in
there were the people who supported
Trump for just the reasons you said and
they're gonna get angry about that
because they're gonna see that as a
betrayal on the other hand all the
people pushing him toward are never
gonna vote for him they despise him in a
no-win situation what do you think he's
gonna find a way to restore deterrence
without getting involved and that's hard
to do yeah Adam Kinzinger congressman we
invited him on the show tonight we're
gonna try to get him on later this week
he was asked today about whether
Congress should give its imprimatur to
military action in Syria this is how one
I think what the president did a year
ago in destroying one-fifth of Assad's
Air Force
was good it was right and I think we
have to do that again people are gonna
say that any use of military force is
gonna be World War three or it's gonna
mean 300 thousand troops in Syria
it isn't does the president need to come
to Congress to get authorization to do
whatever that next military act is I
don't think so well that's convenient
for Congress then they're not on the
hook if stuff goes awry or something
less exactly that's exactly what
Congress does when they are against
something they say you have to come on
there for something you don't and if it
goes well they join in on the take
credit and if it doesn't go well it's
orphan and Shore fault
so what Trump has to do and I he's got
some really good advisers I can't I'm
sleep soundly tonight because of Pompeo
and mattis and bolt and I think they're
advising him that we have to stop this
idea that you can hijack a US boat or
send a missile at a US carrier or point
nuclear weapons but we can't go in and
try to nation-build and make them like
Carmel California in between those two
polls we've got to do something and I
think there's a way to shock the
Russians and the Syrians so that we
don't have to get in there on the ground
and get bogged down but it's gonna it's
not easy and we gotta first of all we
got to ascertain whether there was WMD
remember the Obama administration said
chlorine doesn't count that was the
first that's rising gas ever used in
World War one it's not really WMD so
where we were right so we've had nothing
but misinformation about the status of
WMD going back to the Iraq war once
we've got to ascertain did they use WMD
and did they kill the innocent children
and did they break their word the
Russians in the series our credibility
on the line if it is we have to send a
message and we have to do it in such a
way that we don't destroy the fragile
political matrix that don't a very
complicated situation and professor we
appreciate your analysis